[Music]
will you marry me
[Music]
baby how did we break up don't call me
baby quiet while I'm talking this is how
he treats me all the time but I know you
you don't know me and I wouldn't have
done it and if you I don't know you
please stop interrupting me
the thing is I would have never done
this to somebody that I that I loved
when I got down on again I got
interrupted like when was the last time
you guys talked ten years ago when we
were on that bench okay nothing since
then and even you would say to him now
well you know I don't hold any grudge
yeah passes in the past yeah past in the
past and I don't hold me hard feelings
for Jeff anymore yeah I mean look
hindsight is 20/20 but looking back
anything you would have done differently
yeah I probably would know what on the
show at all
yeah I would have waited so I was a
little bit older I think it was a little
too young to go on the show is 22 if you
weren't in love with me I mean I'm just
not sure why like why you may love a
thing well first of all I think that's
kind of below the belt I think that's
something that should be private and
kept private the things I said to you
the way I kissed you the way I looked at
you those things were real and and your
take on it might have been somewhat
different than mine mine but it was real
for me why did you bring up the fact
that you had had sex with Andy why were
you willing to tell the world well I
mean I was probably as caught off-guard
that I or surprised that I said that is
anyone I didn't come in there with
expectation you know that being said I
mean that was absolutely a question that
you know when things ended that when I
went home and you know thought about and
played it through my head that I mean I
was probably the number one question out
of my mind but I think it was just you
know when she came out I was you know
obviously was in a mostly charged
environment I had just got done watching
you know the finale like everyone else
and I was will take him back I think by
her demeanor and very call a little cold
there was seem to be like a complete
lack of empathy and had I planned on and
I think maybe I would have tried to be a
little bit more delicate but that being
said I mean is something that weighed on
my heart and weighing on my mind and it
wasn't just about the
it was more to me about the intimacy and
like I said the fiance type stuff and I
think maybe I if I could have just art
art articulated that a little bit more
kissing nick is great it was fun and
sexy and passionate when we're together
it's like oh I don't want this night to
end
[Music]
[Music]
I did not know that is I think it was
probably mics from the camera because we
didn't have mics on waking up in the
morning I definitely am feeling guilt I
don't necessarily feel guilty about the
act it's more just guilt from caring
about other relationships that I have
and I've never done this before I've
never dated this many guys and had to
feel this guilt and I do I think the
only regret that I would have is the
timing of it just because of what's
right and wrong in that world of you
know maybe hurting other guys feelings
that is not something that I ever wanted
to do I am in love with two women here
pent I love you I love you too that's
crazy I can't believe that Ben told me
that he loves me this is the happiest
I've ever felt in my entire life sorry
it's hard for me to like talk about it I
feel like I make you love me
today's the best day of my life I don't
know how you can be in love with two
women and then propose to one and say
goodbye to the other I'm in deep trouble
yes when this was going on I love two
women but now I'm happily in love with
one and that's gonna stay that way for
the rest of my life that woman that
you've chosen have you addressed the
being in love with two women thing with
her what's that conversation like right
away I felt like it was something that I
need to talk about I knew that I
couldn't say goodbye I was in love with
to him but I knew I couldn't say goodbye
to the woman that I that I was with in
the end and so I need to share with her
like my feelings you know we're
confusing at times but I never doubted
our relationship and it took me thinking
about who I couldn't say goodbye to for
the rest of my life to really make that
decision and it was her we're a team now
and a team teams communicate they have
to even in situations that are tough and
difficult and so I had to communicate
with her and she's been supportive and
loving and caring understanding it's not
always easy right we put her through
hell and back sometimes but she's never
ceased to love me and support me through
it and that's why we're standing today
and I have I'm so excited
[Applause]
oh that feels good
she's in the pool this is 30 minutes
into paradise and it is already going
down
well they are having a one-on-one top
gun moment in the pool the incident
happened right after that like at that
very moment of us getting into the pool
and everything that's when we had kind
of got you know a little more cozier you
know so to speak and everything happened
and it just finished and we were like
finished and we're like let's go party
some more let's go some drinks you know
it was a very like organic very casual
you know we went and you know we went to
ITM like you know like the in the moment
and you know you kind of discuss like
what's going on who are you filling and
it was you know it was hype it was that
was the start of paradise like a lot of
people were kind of like wow you know
you guys started off paradise I don't
know
No what's up what's the deal hate to do
this do this really confused right now
what's going on tomorrow where Brent
where's cream cut it down okay well I
just feel like what happened was kind of
really private and yeah I actually told
him last night I was like you ran to the
media so mad at you and he was like no I
did it like I only went to the media
after your statement came out and it was
just a bunch of just like mish-mosh I
don't even care to hash it out name
where it is what it is but I did express
it to him and I was upset that we
couldn't have just handled it privately
and you know but you know what
everything happens for a reason and
we're all good now so I'm able to just
hang out with him as friends and have
fun be ourselves so it just feels great
Oh
I think for me the more I hung out with
you the more I felt like I was losing
the possibility of maybe reconciling
things with Lauren do you want to be
back with her I want to see if there's
that possibility are you giving me for
me I just wanted there to be no
questions on on that breakup I know that
it's a very public relationship and I
feel like doing it on camera would just
let everyone know that that decision was
solely mine and and it it told the story
of how I ended up here with her and
that's why I wanted it to be captured do
you think that you're 100% over Becca
yes thousand percent I feel like I just
I made the wrong decision you know and I
feel terrible but I know my heart's with
you I'll always be with you
we've had a lot of conversations about
it and I trust him and I don't think
that he would have taken such a huge
risk and faced all this backlash if he
wasn't really serious about this
decision
have you guys ever talked again no no I
mean just like filming wise but that was
it yeah nothing else what would you say
if you ran into him well I don't even
know what that would say like huh I'd
probably high-five and be like yeah he's
a cute baby
he does a okay yeah have you and Lauren
ever talked no mm-hmm how would things
be there
I think fine I mean I think it'd be fine
for me
I mean at this point like they're happy
I'm very happy with Garrett that I don't
think there's any hopefully there's no
bad blood there but yeah I don't know
I just needed to get away you just jump
it dance really sounds like I know you
always say this but like a moment the
show has never seen before to see the
producers on camera to see the
franticness of it all were you just
thinking what are we gonna do from here
it really was unlike anything we dealt
with before and so for the first you
know five minutes I thought we're
clearly gonna find him it's not that big
of a deal
and then we didn't how long did it take
to find it someone asked me that I
really don't know if wholly he is gone
how long were you gone for and where did
you go in that darkness I was gone for
quite a bit Chris was chasing after me
trying to find me I just needed to get
away I needed time and I think I
realized you know I I wanted I wanted to
just be to myself and sit in that moment
my myself and realized what's best for
me as a human being
[Music]